hi i'm ben barnes and i play general
kerrigan hello
i'm archie renault and i play mel i'm
jessie maylie and i play alina
hi i'm freddie carter and i play kaz
brecker hi i'm amita suman and
i play inner gaffer i'm kit young i play
jasper
in shadow and bone we are going to take
the quiz to find out if we would survive
a journey
through the shadow fold with buzzfeed
first question what is your greatest
strength i'm super patient
i'm extremely dedicated i'm creative i'm
a natural born leader
i'm a problem solver i'm always willing
to try new things
i think i'm a natural-born leader i've
gone with um dedicated
i'm gonna go patient i would say i'm a
problem solver
i'm gonna go for i'm creative okay
definitely not super patient
i'm gonna go with uh i'm always willing
to try new things
which will probably mean i'm gonna end
up dead which book that has been adapted
into a movie or
tv show are you bringing with you to
pass the time the fellowship of the ring
by j.r
tolkien little women by louisa may
alcott a game of thrones by george r.r
martin
normal people by sally rooney little
fires everywhere by celeste in
pride and prejudice by jane austen ship
of the ring
i'm gonna go for little women that's a
childhood favorite i'm gonna go with
normal people by sally rooney because i
that's the most recent of those books
that i've read for me it's gotta be
friendship with the ring oh it's got to
be
which shadow and bone character would
you trust with a secret
elena kaz inez general kirigan
jesper or mao i'm going mao i'm going
mal as well
yeah i wouldn't trust any of the crows
mean the meter you're going to pick
yourself aren't you
uh 100 yeah she's the secret keeper
i'm gonna go elena definitely wouldn't
be me would it let's be honest
throw that in your face you trusted me
with a secret about flowers at one point
no
don't think it paid off alina is
trustworthy but also i feel like she
does tell jenny things
i'm gonna go for a nudge i'm gonna go
mal i think he's good at keeping a
secret
yeah honest good guy all right which
random superpower would you love to have
cool the power to learn any language
how to remember everything you read the
power to know when someone is lying
would i want to know that how to change
anything into food
about to transform into any animal and
the power to control
the weather oh that's hard these are
hard
i'd have to go power to transform into
an animal yeah i think that's about it
it's so good if you wanted to get
through the fall turning into an ant is
probably
quite a good one to
great options the power to remember
everything you read
that'd be great yeah yeah never have a
problem with glowing
lines i think to learn any language can
you imagine how useful you'd be and how
much you could get done yeah well a
meter already
feels that way because she's what she's
speaking like learn three or four quite
a few
i speak three i'm gonna go for the
language i feel like
if you remember everything you read then
technically you're learning a language
no you can't you can't blur the powers
and have bows you have to choose one
i'm gonna go with the power to transform
into any animal because then i can
breathe underwater and i can fly and he
could turn into a vulcan and then he
could cross the field
that too that's all thinking first first
on my list
which gracious speciality would you want
to have a healer an inferni
a tide maker a fabricator a squalor or a
heart render
i've answered this one before saying i
would love to be a heart render because
they can use their powers
you know in a sort of assertive powerful
way to cut someone's blood supply or
burst their heart but then they can also
soothe and calm i think actually i'm
gonna go for a fabric cage i feel like
that would be helpful you could probably
invent something or make something to
help you
get through the fold i'm gonna have to
applicator yeah i've always said
fabricator i like building yeah i think
that would be quite fun
i think i know which one you're going to
go with freddie inferno yeah that's what
i thought you'd do
i don't like being cold i'm going to go
for fabric
i'm going heart random man because my
favorite one isn't on there which is
shadow summoner but you know that's
because they're evil we don't need more
of that if we're crossing the fold no we
don't need for that so i'm gonna go with
heart render
to keep everyone calm on your journey
you keep talking about their tv
show your love what show are you talking
about shit's creek
bridgeton one division the crown
grey's anatomy or the queen's gambit
it's got me the queen scan but for me i
loved it i thought it was so good
i've gotta go with one division it's
just like endlessly
i've gotta say i've not watched any of
these i've watched an episode of the
crown
a guy broke into the queen's bedroom and
had a chat and a cup of tea with her i
have to go for the crown
gray's anatomy wouldn't exactly be the
best thing to calm someone down when
you're in the shadow
if someone gets hurt and then you're
talking about a hospital drama where
people are in crisis left and right i'm
not sure i'd pick that i feel like
bridgeton it's probably not the best
time to
hook up with someone the queen's gambit
is a pretty good one yeah
you're going to have to go for some
playing chess yeah i think
i think i'm going to go with shit's
creek though keep everyone happy and
smiling
finally what is your biggest fear being
trapped in a small space
flying losing a loved one fights letting
your friends down
spiders oh losing a loved one um
yeah i mean it's gotta be anything it's
gonna be that one for me
easy amazing
i remember being terrified watching hook
as a kid when they put
they put the guy in that little chest
full of crabs i think that scarfed me
for life
usually the size of my bedroom that i
had small spaces no problem
oh my god what did you get
congratulations you survived the journey
through the shuttle
read the phone yes of course the crows
would make it
i didn't i don't kid did you not make it
sorry but it looks like you didn't make
it back out of the shadowfeld
while you were inside the volcker proved
to be too tough to handle
as well as the many other mysteries hey
i survived
yeah i survived as well we're veterans
at this shadowful
thing now walk in the park walk in a
very dark park that's really upsetting
i'm gonna have to retake that for my own
time
i am not dying in the shadow fold i'm a
sore loser today thank you buzzfeed make
sure you go and watch shadow on bone on
netflix
you